did you drive over here in that Tesla
yeah man yes sure did
did you get one yet I didn't get one man
but the new ones I think you're coming
out with an American flag hanging off
the back we were talking about this
yesterday man and it was literally the
funniest thing and I talked about in a
while just the fact that well Elon Musk
tweeted some stuff what did he write
Nick
he wrote the the quarantine quarantine
is stupid
yeah and then he's on some like free let
me open up yeah he wouldn't open his
business in Redmond I think it is
Alameda County Redmond he said they were
gonna have to arrest him he was just
gonna put his workers on the line yeah
he tweeted take the red pill yeah got a
lot of people it's he basically like all
the people who all the liberals who
bought a Tesla or now like what I do cuz
I love when anybody gets [ __ ] over I
don't care it's [ __ ] hilarious
it's kind of like when Hulk Hogan
started wearing that black stuff
everyone he started to a monster right
yeah I remember it and you're like what
is going on yes oh yeah that's so
bizarre yeah but you tweeted something
too about it didn't you it was so funny
man did you tweet something about it no
I mean I've tweeted like I'm on the side
of like scientists and stuff yeah that's
funny that's a line on the right and all
the holy lawns like I got a lecture I
believe in electric the electric future
brother yeah mag America gasoline las'
again baby yeah it's all canceled
culture he's just been going in yeah
he's a basically just awesome Magus it
it's correct he's some piece dong zhuo's
podcast twice he's like what the [ __ ]
who is this guy liberals are gonna have
to get now they're all stuck with the
cars and I see what the cars is you
can't lease them right i you can i least
mine I didn't think you could but you
can't I thought you had no idea yeah am
I gonna get rid of this thing just
coming
stuck with this electric American flag
and good afternoon and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw I mean it was okay but the next
video you can watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or watch this one watch this
one watch this one watch this one